Now, Republicans have been saying the inspector
general is investigating the Russia probe.
When that report comes out, you will see how
the entire Russia probe was a completely inappropriate
witch hunt, inappropriately run, uh, and also
based on political bias and the Trump, Ian
Wright has had a lot riding on this for awhile.
They've put a lot of eggs in this office of
the inspector general report.
Uh, and yesterday the office of the inspector
general published the report and it says that
the Russia probe was done in total correctly
with proper limits carried out in the right
way without political bias.
Now they did find some specific procedural
pieces that were problematic, which I will
tell you about.
I have no interest in hiding that from you,
but certainly not the bombshell that Republicans
and Trumpists were promising.
So let's go through it.
The report is more than 400 pages.
The highlights include that the FBI had a
quote authorized purpose when it started its
investigation.
The investigation was not opened because of
political animus from the FBI against Donald
Trump.
Informants were not used in violation of the
FBI's rules, so it's a clean bill of health
for the investigation with a few elements
of a wrongdoing.
What were those elements?
Well, the report says that once the inventor
investigation got going, they believe the
FBI would sometimes emphasize information
that made Trump look bad and downplay information
that made Trump look good.
Now remember, this is still an office that
is not without political bias, but let's grant
it to them.
Because the entire structure and framework
of the investigation has been vindicated.
I'm fine granting that.
Maybe that is something that took place.
Here's an excerpt from the report regarding
another area of controversy, which is that
the surveillance of Carter page specifically
was heavily based on the steel dossier.
The FBI request form drew almost entirely
from Steele's reporting in describing the
factual basis to establish, establish probable
cause, to believe that Carter page was an
agent of a foreign power.
Now again, I say let's just accept the criticism
and move on.
Let them have it.
Let them have the critique that specifically
the surveillance of Carter page was too heavily
based on the Steele dossier.
It's a sliver of this entire thing.
Let them have it.
Bearing in mind of course, that lots of that
Steele dossier was later corroborated.
Now, Donald Trump's attorney general henchman
William Barr disagrees with the report.
That probably doesn't surprise you.
He believes that the report, uh, is just flat
out wrong.
Of course, that it should have been much more
um, uh, critical of the way the investigation
was carried out.
So big picture.
I don't know how much time we need to spend
on this.
Both sides are claiming victory.
Democrats claim the report completely exonerates
the way the investigation was carried out,
Republicans claim that it's devastating.
The reality is the report is mostly exculpatory
of the FBI's investigation into Donald Trump
and Russia in any huge long investigation
like this.
It's not shocking that there were a few procedural
issues that the report was able to find my
guesses.
If you do this deep of an investigation into
any major government investigation, you would
find some items that at this level of granularity
could have been better handled.
That is not hugely surprising to me.
It doesn't excuse anything, but it's not hugely
surprising.
What you have to remember is Republicans hyped
this report to Helen back and other than being
able to say, well, the Carter page surveillance
was based too heavily on the Steele dossier.
FBI officials played up certain things unfairly
to Trump once it got going.
That's all they have.
They are almost better off ignoring the report
altogether rather than pretend that it's devastating
to the Russia probe because it's not.
And what we have to do is ensure that we don't
allow the report to be misrepresented.
This is a totally unsurprising conclusion
to the report.
It's good that it's done.
We can now try to start moving on from this
talking point from Republicans who have been
saying, just you wait until that OIG report
destroys this an entire investigation that's
over.
Let's just make sure we don't let them continue
the false
talking points.